Michael burry the world famous investor
who is featured in the movie The Big
Short he recently sold all of his stock
except for one and he's predicting a
massive market crash now Michael burry
runs sky on asset management and he's
got over a hundred million dollars
invested in the U.S stock market which
means that he has to publicly report all
of his positions and at the end of Q2 of
this year he sold 11 equities his entire
portfolio and he kept only one Geo Group
which is a private prison stock NOW
Michael burry made a ton of money back
in 2008 2009 when he predicted the
housing crisis and he positioned himself
to profit handsomely now Michael burry
dumping all of his stock at the end of
Q2 means that he raised a bunch of cash
and he's sitting waiting for this big
crash where then he can buy back assets
at much lower prices he sold stocks like
Google and Facebook and it looks like he
simply wants to hold just that one
private prison stock Michael burry is a
Perma bear he constantly thinks the
Market's gonna go down he constantly is
looking for the next big score but
anytime that he isn't just talking and
instead he's actually repositioning the
portfolio it's worth paying attention to
because if Michael burries right he
stands to make a lot of money and it
also means that most of you will see
your portfolios go down in value whether
he's right or not the market will
determine but any time that someone has
skinned in the game and makes a big move
like this it's worth paying attention to
and it's also kind of crazy the only
stock that he has confidence in is a
stock that literally makes money as we
put more humans in cages hey you did you
like this video great make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time